welcome to a Collider heroes interview I
am coach Andre I'm Amy Dallen and with
us
Joseph David Jones so I am gonna dive
right in because next week is arrow and
I am very excited this has been a long
time running this show has been going
and you've also gotten to be a part of
another show within this universe
does it feel different working on one
show or the other does it feel like one
big family it's it's funny because like
the show like I was on legends of
tomorrow when I first started out and
they were still like in the first season
so they were still trying to like find
where they fit in the tone that they
wanted things like I'm talking like 17
18 hour days yeah I'm like arrow it's
like a well-oiled machine like they know
it works they know what fans like they
know it shots they're trying to get so
days are like and it's crazy I mean we
do we do have those like days where it's
like 15 16 hours still but for the most
part like everybody knows what they're
trying to get they know what the fans
are gonna enjoy and like we're all just
working towards that so it's like trying
to get in rhythm with everyone that's
great and you may be a big part of this
the finals show of the whole arrowverse
what has that been like just looking
forward to that it is it's funny cuz I
mean I binge watched everything early
last season when I like you know got the
call and they asked if I could come back
and reprise the role and everything and
they have like a Bible of everything
that has ever happened on arrow and this
this eighth season is meant to be like
you know the culmination of the show
you're not just trying to tie up the
season and the bad guy for that season
they're trying to tie up everything so
there are so many callbacks to just
things like tiny moments in earlier
seasons and like you read it in the
script and you're like holy like who's
keeping track and it's like you know
season 2 episode 22 you know Oliver
walks in the room this way and like
they'll like they'll match that and it's
like the attention to detail that
they're putting into this season just to
give fans these like little Easter eggs
that they can call back to it's amazing
I think they want people like go back
and re-watch especially the first season
because they're gonna be a lot of
callbacks to like the first season in
early arrow yeah
and that's super common key I liked it
to show Joseph it's like by the way time
doesn't really matter because we know
how to match cut you can flip a panel me
back in early arrow and you can watch a
show be back in early arrow waiting for
the show that doesn't mean while that's
coming now arrow is a show that really
restructured what comic book TV is arrow
changed the game in a big web I remember
I was I was working at the LA Fitness
and Stephen Amell had that giant poster
outside that was just definitely worked
out way harder because of that big but
when that came out we all thought it was
gonna be like a one or two season maybe
three like we didn't think it was going
to change television were you watching
back then universe yeah I was and it's
funny he's like the first and second
season like my favorite yes of this
thing and I mean it's it's it's
hilarious because they're still like
finding it in those seasons they're
finding it in those years it was so good
man I mean and it spawned a whole
universe you know it's several universes
I'm like looking off I'm like man it's
it's sad and it's it's funny because I
mean I was just coming on when they made
the announcement and everything and
Stephen he had come to set and he'd like
just called this powwow and everyone
stopped for a second and he was like
letting him know that he was coming back
for one more season and he had talked to
Guggenheim and talked to Brittany and
they had like said this is these are how
many episodes I feel like we need to do
the story justice and to close it off in
a way that the fans will love and like
everyone
his facebook announcement post was so
like it was like five minutes later man
it was just wow wow but there's a beauty
to have something having a beginning
middle and end and we know of course
that the the universe created there is
going to continue and you get to be
there for the big finale
yeah I'm just broadly out of curiosity
are you as we as comic book fans are
excited for some kind of crisis on
Infinite Earths oh my god yes I mean
it's it's like the biggest crossover
that's ever been done in history and
it's it's huge for the network how much
I can say about this but like mark
he went to Warner Brothers with like
[Laughter]
Tupac lazer hologram of Christopher E we
do also have the I'm calling it the
canary over because we got the black
canary show yeah I really the canary
overs so I love that we live in a time
where even with a show ending there's a
lot of characters that gets to spin off
into another show and like yeah I'm
going is it like a family on set when
you're working with people that have
worked together for so long since it's
been eight years do they all have
shorthand as well as the team does it's
funny cuz like okay we the show in large
part has been compartmentalized from
last season and it's because we're in
the flash-forwards yeah you know so
there there hasn't been a lot of
overlapping hmm with like shoot days
it's crazy so we're constantly and until
someone's brought to the Future or you
know they Don the old
you know we don't get to meet him we're
gonna get to like you know hang out with
them but like this season because
everything's been like sort of ending
there have been a lot of attempts to
like bring everybody together and like
yeah that sort of camaraderie in the
family so like I don't know we we send
the show off right with the this love
for everything so I really feel like in
this last season I've grown so much
closer with the rest of the cast I mean
they're all hilarious so it's it's it's
really been great I'm like answering a
question like well Season seven as much
as you want cuz that's totally fair yeah
but I I think I just keep getting sad
when I'm like thinking about it because
okay they'll be scenes whatever knows
will be like guys this is the last time
we're gonna be you know in this room
together you know this is the last time
we're gonna be shooting here and it's
like man that's bad you know it's funny
because I'm like in the middle of
talking about it in the weight of that
sort of it's you in the middle of saying
it but no it really has been like a
family moreso to them than us but like
we feel like they've really adopted us
into their arrowverse family and it
feels kind of sad it feels kind of sad
but we'll we'll see what happens with
this this spin-off show yeah and and how
you know how how many people also get to
have the joy of knowing that it like
it's it's looking to perversely great
for us to hear that you all will miss it
if that makes sense because that love
comes through that love for what you're
doing and for the people that you're
working with so thank you we're very
sorry but you tell us a little bit about
being Connor what's the most fun about
it oh god the fight scenes it's funny
because I love a love doing stunts I
love doing the action stuff
they have a an amazing stunt team on
arrow and every single time they
write something into the scrip I'm like
can I do this alright we'll see but like
I spend so much time with their with
their stunt team with their coordinators
trying to like learn as much of my
fights as I can
yeah and it's why they have like a
couple guys who have doubled me this
season but the the one who is carried
over from last season this man named
Dennis Lafond and he is like he's like
master of his craft so I was like
working with him any day that I'm not on
setting that he's here yeah I can like
learn as much as I can I love that much
respect for some people that's such a
hard job and so like that that means the
casting directors and some people need
Oscars yesterday like that is really
underappreciated and it's it's luckily
we have like amazing team especially
with all the stuff that they're doing
this season because they're they're
turning it up to like 10 yeah you see
that in the pilot episode it's this will
be when the far yeah by the time this
where we're mere days away from the drop
of the premieres October 15th I assume
you've already set your various TVs now
I've a I have a slightly askew from
arrow question for you directly you've
worked at two of my favorite directors
in the world who Kathryn Bigelow and Dan
Gilroy I got a no what's it like to be
on a set with like either of those
Titans of filmmaking it's funny the both
of the processes are so different and I
would say like Kathryn Bigelow was sort
of the easiest to fold into and if
anything it kind of it kind of spoils
you for other projects because the way
that she shoots is is literally to let
you have free rein in this so so they'll
create a scene and like in Detroit there
were riots and there were explosions and
everything going off and they would just
let you live in that scene and each take
didn't
have to be the same you didn't have to
match anything and they would have
cameras hidden hmm so you wouldn't even
know where the cameras were you were
just like put into an environment and
like living through it as the character
Wow so it was like her trying to capture
these moments of us living living in
this space and it's like big wish I wish
it was always like that because most of
the time it's like hitting marks and
beats and like recreating from turn
around and all this stuff so it feels a
bit contrived on some levels with with
other projects and I mean it says that's
like you know acting for film versus
like being a play man it sounds like a
play if there's just cameras in places
and you're doing a scene and you feel
that like a you you I don't know maybe
fall in love with working with her with
Dan Gilroy I I did the table read first
before I you know learned who I was
playing or anything and the table read
had such high profile people there that
I was like sitting there like what am I
doing here
but like like I go into the table read
or whatever they had my name set up and
like right next to it's like Colin
Farrell and I didn't tell Washington and
I'm like don't lose your only chance to
become friends with Denzel but he I
don't know he's a very very grounded and
down there person and like he's one of
the only people that know who just like
shoots LA for LA do his movies capture
it whatever with the you know the tax
incentives he's like I love working in
LA I love like shooting here and being
here and he does the city justice and
everything but I don't know I everything
that I shoot shoots somewhere else hmm
yeah every day you never get to work
here and it's like ah that's hard and I
get it the Dan Gilroy Zod Nightcrawler
it's the best Valley representation I've
ever seen it feels like the valley the
movies so good mmm
and it's a it's really like called me
again to be an invalid buzzsaw and like
it was like I had a conflict oh yeah I
was like that movie's crazy to tanker
always got a very like his broad
sensibility of comedies amazing I'm a
big fan so anything you want from the
world of well so we don't touch on
season eight too deeply because I want
to see it as a fan is there anything you
want in the world of the arrowverse
going forward as a fan like I got
another show on a thing like anything
not touching on arrow you'd like to see
down the line and Batwoman or flash I'd
like to see it's funny because they're
making so many different things and it's
funny like on Batwoman I think my
favorite character in the DC Universe
exists it's and I was like man like that
would be an amazing story to tell like I
mean it effectively becomes like the
black Batman and it's like holy crap I
want to see that movie but there have
been two different versions of batwing
one was God I'm gonna butcher this name
and everyone's gonna destroy me in the
comments but it's like David oh oh um be
David or can be the character's name oh
you're pulling it up yes our audience
I'm sorry they understand names are very
dead but he's like he becomes a batwing
in in Egypt so yeah like it's like a
combination of like Batman meets Black
Panther yeah and it's with a dash of
moonlight my god I wanna like that I
want that to be a movie you know yeah
yeah it's a VIN Bay David's a bindi ah
thank ya
that guy that that's the dense names of
comic books there's so many characters
like so many things totally I DC wiki
has been like
let's go and learn man it's so concise
but that's what comic book fans do we
find the who's who we just trade
encyclopedia and Laura tips that's part
of the fun of it right right without
giving too much away like I cuz there's
so many Easter eggs in this crossover
this year I've had to like read my
scripts doing the work that's rad I'm so
excited for this crossover like Tom
Welling coming back I Smallville was my
childhood I'm so excited this thing's
gonna be insane yeah like Steven
facilitated that hardcore himself like
he he really liked when sabaton was like
guys we gotta get him in here like he I
mean he cares so much about this
universe and and especially like arrow
like he's the biggest master of
continuity yeah this show and knowing
like it's crazy because he'll he'll be
in a place for whatever and know exactly
which day they shot there which episode
it aired on and like so he's talking
about who knows everything that happens
on the show we got a cut nasty even what
the continuity you guys will be like it
was 2013 on a Tuesday and I think it was
a bit rainy and like no exactly so when
they're doing coverage on not Stephen
Amell he script D he's now doing the
salmon he's like no it was raining can
we talk oh my god it's like that that is
like a rite of passage on the show
because like everybody who joins the
show especially fair guy even if they're
a girl cuz like a lot of the girls have
done the Salmon Ladder but they watch
that first episode and it's like I have
to be them yeah oh my god what's wrong
if you don't get up and work out after
that first episode come on
that's the rocky moment that is that's
there's and that is the moment very
important now I can talk to aro all day
and I very much look forward to we got
to have you back on after you can talk
about this season yeah I don't want to
give anything away for season a but at
the end of season eight will definitely
Rican spire post crises
two very hard-hitting questions y know
if there was an alternate universe
version of you what would he be doing of
me personally um I don't know maybe it'd
be like a musician or something if
there's another musical crossover are
you down it's funny because we joke
about that so I think literally all of
the new cast will be down fandom make it
happen internet make sure to tweet
everyone to get another musical episode
behind this man I'm excited to talk to
you after we can actually talk about it
thanks for joining us today me thank you
and see you guys